ابدا معك جفارا جفارا وهذا الخبر العاجل
قراناه قبل قليل نقلا عن اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي باعتراض طائره مسيره من لبنان
في منطقه عكا دون تفعيل صفارات
الانذار بالفعل هذا ما اعلنه الجيش
الاسرائيلي قبل قليل بانه تم اعتراض على
ما يبدو مسيره وتحدث عن جسم مشبوه اخترق
الحدود مع لبنان اخترق المجال الجوي وان
القبه الحديديه تمكنت من اعتراض هذه
المسيره فوق منطقه عكا عند اي فوق البحر
بمعنى ان هذه المسيره اخترقت المجال الجوي
الاسرائيلي ولكن من جهه البحر وتم
اعتراضها ولم تدوي صافرات الانذار كما
اضاف بيان الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه تم تنفيذ
غارات وقصف مدفعي على اكثر من موق قع داخل
الجنوب اللبناني خلال الساعتين الماضيتين
تحديدا قرب قريه الراميه وايضا في كفار
كلا والحوله وانه تم تنفيذ هذه العمليات
اتجاه مواقع وبنى عسكريه ومباني تابعه
لحزب الله على طول خط الجنوب اللبناني
واضح عبد القادر ان التصعيد لازال متواصلا
على جانبي الحدود فرغم عدم دوي صافرات
الانذار خلال يوم امس وحتى هذه اللحظه الا
ان الصافرات دوت يوم امس ليس في الجنوب
اللبنا في المناطق المتاخمه للجنوب
اللبناني ولكن في جنوبي هضبه الجولان
السوري المحتل وتم رصد اطلاق قذائف على
الاقل ثلاثه قذائف سقطت في مناطق مفتوحه
وتم الرد كما قال الجيش على مصادر اطلاق
النار داخل الاراضي السوريه ولكن ايضا
جانبا من التصعيد الميداني هناك جانب من
التصعيد السياسي خلال محادثه اجراها وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي مع نظيره الامريكي
اوستن قال جلنت على الجبهه
الشماليه سنصل قريبا الى نقطه الحسم نواصل
الوصول الى تسويه ولكن قد نصل في النهايه
الى نقطه الحزم بمعنى شن الحرب على لبنان
ولكن هو يتحدث بالطبع عن حزب الله اضافه
لذلك قال جلنت ان التسويه جام is